quoi de mieux que du vin et du fromage
pour mieux faire connaître le terroir
français à des canadiens dans le cadre
d'un échange
une vingtaine d'étudiants de l'école des
métiers de la restauration et du
tourisme de montréal a été accueilli par
leurs homologues guyancourt toi la
france est le pays le plus visité au
monde
du rose clientèle pour nous au canada
donc c'était c'était c'était quelque
chose
passage obligé sont vus avant d'en
apprendre plus sur les accords vins
fromages le groupe d'étudiants a pu
visiter des grands magasins parisiens ou
encore le château de versailles
l'occasion également de comparer leur
formation dans le domaine du tourisme
je trouve qu'il ya un an des cours de
marketing par exemple que nous on a pas
eu
mais je trouve qu'on se rejoindre sur
beaucoup d'aspects par exemple quand on
fait les tours guidés
c'est assez semblable à ce que nous on a
dû faire on a remarqué quelques
différences entre l'école française et
l'école au canada prendra pas plus parlé
de ça mais en fait on a voulu apprendre
à se connaître à prendre les diverses
expressions les la culture parce que
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment très
différent
c'est la première fois qu'un partenariat
est noué entre le lycée d'hôtellerie de
guyancourt et un établissement canadien
ouvrir nos étudiants à des parcours
internationaux à ce pour l'instant
effectivement ils sont uniquement sur un
parcours européen et je pense
effectivement qu'il ya des opportunités
de travail au niveau du canada et
notamment au niveau du québec l'année
prochaine il est prévu que les étudiants
juillan courtois partent à leur tour à
la découverte du terroir canadien